Toma a level zero esper living in
Academy city has a unique ability and
allows him to nullify psychic magical
and divine Powers while running from the
thugs he meets masaka Makoto a powerful
level five psychic capable of
controlling and generating electricity
she helps our boy to deal with the thugs
but taunts him for being level zero when
Tomah tells her to chill out she attacks
him only for her attack to get nullified
to her surprise the next morning Tomah
wakes up to find a young nun from the
church of England hanging off his
balcony introducing herself as index she
reveals that she is being chased by
magicians because she has 103 000
grimoires tonal questions the
authenticity of her story and asks her
to provide proof by performing magic
however she's unable to because she has
no Mana Toma tells her that magic does
not exist however the supernatural truly
exists as Academy city is the home of
espers people who have supernatural
abilities and tells her that he himself
has a supernatural ability on his right
hand which he states can cancel any
Supernatural occurrences even Divine
things index irritated by his beliefs
tells him her outfit is named The
Walking Church a magical item that
protects her from harm she runs to the
kitchen grabs a sharp knife and tells
him to stab her and it will not hurt her
Tomah promptly rejects the offer and
notes that if it really is Magic his
right hand will dispel its abilities in
response index teases that it will
happen only if his power is authentic
irritated at her he accepts her
Challenge and touches her robes and for
a few seconds nothing happens however
this eventually rips apart her clothes
making her naked later after fixing her
robe by using clothing pins index tries
to leave as she believes magicians are
closing in on her Toma being hospitable
tells her that she is allowed to stay in
his apartment if she want it however she
refuses index later leaves as well as
Toma as he has remedial classes to
attend to Toma has a conversation with
his friends alagami and Moto Haru on how
kamoya their teacher likes him and how
Toma is lucky enough to spend time with
her while returning home Toma encounters
Makoto once again where she demands
another fight against him he simply
ignores her she however makes him notice
her by pounding her foot on the ground
which causes an electric surge on nearby
electrical equipment this causes Tomah
to complain about her using her powers
that cause him great inconvenience and
why she has always attacked him even
though he has laid not a single finger
on her their conversation later ends
abruptly as security robots reactivate
and pursue them prompting them to run
away he later returns home to see that
index is on the ground surrounded by
several cleaning robots in front of his
apartment door however he soon learns
that index is severely injured and is
bleeding profusely Tomah wonders who did
this to her when a man with red hair and
long black row appears before him
telling him that it was their doing
the magician tells him that his partner
did not intend to injure her as the
walking church is supposed to protect
index Toma asks why they did this to her
and the magician states that she
contains within her brain the 103 000
volumes of grimoire and needed to
recover and protect it this egregious
Tomah and he tries to attack the
magician but he simply Dodges it style
then summons Flames into his hands and
uses it to attack Tomah however he
surprises style as he is left unscathed
by his attack
style realizes that Tomah was the one
who destroyed index's walking Church
knowing this he chant his spell and
summons in akentius the witch-hunting
pope at that moment index speaks she
tells them those mystical runes that
were applied in the building Tomah asks
her if she is indexed to which she
answers that indeed that she is index
and right now she is in John's pen mode
style uses tomah's preoccupation and
blocking in akentius to attack which
prompts Tomah to retreat and run Tomah
later finds the area where style applied
the runes however his Discovery is cut
short after Ina kentius continues his
Pursuit on him and he once again
Retreats he fumbles and follows several
stories into a roof shed and then on
several bicycles Tomah realizes that
innerkentius can only move in the area
where the runes were applied and uses
the opportunity to try and contact help
back in the apartment style tries to
recover index but is later surprised to
see the sprinkler system activated his
enraged that Tomah has gotten him wet
for nothing as the lakentius will still
be able to survive in the wet
environment
Tomah returns to the apartment and
states to style on how he would have won
if he instead engraved the Rune markings
on the wall instead of sticking them on
paper he is enraged for a moment after
thinking that Ina kentius has been
defeated however he smiles as
inocentious returns and orders it to
kill Tomah however in akentches soon
dissipates after Tomah uses his right
hand on it
Toma tells to a surprise style that even
if the paper could not be washed away
the ink will style is shaken by this and
tries to use another fire attack on him
however Toma charges towards him and
knocks him out the single punch to the
face
after the battle members of anti-skill
barricade the perimeter around tomah's
apartment to let the fire department do
their duties and to keep civilians out
of the way we see Makoto in the crowd
wondering what's going on when a girl
named Kuroko who calls Makoto Oni Sama
runs up to her Kuroko states that the
fire may be esper related meanwhile
Tomah rests index on a bench and asks
her if she has any magical books inside
her head that can heal her injury index
explains the origins of magic to Toma
she tells him that magic was not meant
for espers as it was intended for the
people who wanted the abilities like
those of espers Tomah realizes that
there are no students in Academy City
that could help index
Tona visits komoy's apartment where he
barges in after she opens the door
tomelay's indexed down on the tatami mat
index glows and returns to Jon's pen
mode index states that she is in
critical condition and asks them to
follow her instructions carefully
Tomah asks kamoya to take care of index
and leaves after index tells him that
his right hand will negate the magic
that will be performed in the room
on a tower that overlooks the city a
woman with long hair holding a long
sword is calmly observing him index
later gets up and creates a pentagram
inside a circle surrounded by symbols
with her own blood she asks kamoya about
the video game memory card and tells her
to put it on the middle of the table
later is revealed to be used as a
miniature model of the room they are in
index then tells kamoye to imagine a
beautiful angel
kamoya tries her best at imagining a
form of an Angel and is successful at
doing so the angel disappears and the
glow from the table disappears as well
index remarks that the healing is
successful and comes out of her John's
pen mode Toma later takes care of index
where they discuss of the dangers of
using magic and where she tells Tomah of
the burden she is carrying she tells
Tomah that she is from the church of
necessary evil or necessarious a
religious organization that hunted
witches because they were using Magic
and was considered evil but the church
needed magic as well to hunt them down
and as such they became the church they
are today also the reason why the church
implanted the 103 000 grimoires into
index was to have them gathered into one
spot and reverse engineer them so they
can neutralize any type of magic
meanwhile style and the long-haired
magician are observing them the
long-haired girl remarks that Tomah is
neither a magician nor an esper and
cannot explain the mystery of his right
hand
a few days later during night time index
and Tomah are traveling towards a bat
house she states that she has no
memories prior to coming to Japan though
she has memories of the fact that her
name is index and that she has grimoires
inside of her head and the name of her
church they later get into an argument
which makes index bite her and run away
Tomah is later seen trying to search for
index however when he gets into an
intersection he notices that everybody
has disappeared for no apparent reason
suddenly kanzaki appears before him and
tells him that it is a room that
specializes in removing people in an
area except them she then introduces
herself to Toma as kanzaki she mentions
that she'd rather not mention her other
name her magic name and requests tomon
Han index over before she does so Toma
asks what happens if he refuses to which
kanzaki demonstrates by showing off her
power and cutting off one of the blades
of a wind turbine kanzaki repeats to
Toma that she wishes to secure index
however Tomah answers to her that he has
no reason to give up this dismays
kanzaki and demonstrates a powerful
attack on Tomah Toma charges towards
kanzaki however she uses her nanoson and
repels him Toma tries to get up once
more which surprises konzaki and attacks
Tomah again with manison
Toma charges through her attack and
tries to cancel it however he realizes
that it is not disappearing and injures
his arm he notices that there are ultra
thin wires that surround them and she
moving them using her Katana and
realizes that she is not using Magic
Toma tries to grab one of the wires
which forces konzaki to hit him with the
Scabbard of her Sword and the kicking
him to the ground
kanzaki tells him that index was her
friend and that she did not mean harm to
her she tells him that if they cannot
secure index then index will not be able
to live she tells Tomah that since index
has the ability to perfectly memorize
anything she cannot forget any
unnecessary memories needed for her
brain keep functioning Tomah asks why
index calls kanzaki and style evil even
when they are from the same church
kanzaki replies that index has no memory
that they are members of the same church
and has concluded on her own that
kanzakian's style are after the 103 000
grimoires inside of her
kanzaki states that index did not lose
her memory but in fact was erased by
them kanzaki states that if they didn't
erase her memories then index would have
died since there was no other way Toma
asked konzaki when the next memory
deletion will take place kanzaki says
that the next one will occur in three
gays Tomah rebutes konzaki for giving up
easily on index but she shouts at him
that he does not understand their own
feelings of presenting themselves as
enemies to index she proceeds to attack
Tomah several times while shouting how
they tried to keep making memories with
her even though she will always forget
even then coma still states that they
are wrong they did not think about index
at all
with kanzaki shaken because of tomah's
speech style returns and asks if she's
finished to which she simply nodded and
then style removes the barrier meanwhile
Makoto and koroko come out of a store
after some shopping and noticed the
blade that was cut from the wind turbine
while waiting for Kuroko Makoto notices
index in the crowd seemingly searching
for something
Tomah wakes up in the tsukiomi residents
being taken care of index however Tomah
realizes that three days has gone by
since he was attacked by kanzaki and
realizes that index still has her
memories index later tries to serve food
for Toma which she fails spectacularly
before being interrupted by someone at
the door
it is revealed that it is kanzaki and
style who are on the front door and have
arrived to take away index however index
thinking that they would hurt Tomah
again offers herself to them and ask
them to stop hurting Toma anymore kamoya
leaves Tomah and index alone for the
entire evening Tomah recalls earlier on
how both style and kanzaki willingly
left them as they would return later and
expecting Toma to not flee with index
Koma later gets a call from kanzaki she
tells him that the limit is at midnight
and they are preparing their schedule to
finish in time
coma asks if magic can't really solve
anything kanzaki tells him that the
church fears index Rebellion is the
holder of the 103 000 room wires as such
the church may have done some
precautions as so index would be unable
to learn a spell to cure her magic can't
save index however Tomah asks konzaki if
they are able to do something the
science side Tomah starts researching
about memory loss and later realizes
that he can ask kamoya to introduce him
to neurological or mental research
institutes he tries to contact kamoya
but she is busy enjoying her bath and
cannot get to her phone
Toma realizes that his already midnight
and index has begun Breathing heavily
kanzakian's style arrives to a race
index of her memories style shows Tomah
and magical cross that is necessary for
deleting her memory and challenges Tomah
to dispel the magic within it if he is
capable of saving her without erasing
her memories Tomah is however unable to
do it and style leads to continue the
ceremony in erasing her memories
Toma in despair asked them to allow him
to say his goodbyes to her
index notices the symbol drawn by Style
on the wall for the ceremony making
index worry however Tomah Collins her
down and apologizes to her and says that
he will become stronger and never lose
again to those who have made her this
way Tomah continued to reprimand himself
for failing to save her after she falls
asleep however he becomes suspicious of
the information regarding index's brain
because of the suspicion behind the
information regarding index of brain he
calls kamoya again and asks her about
perfect memorization and the information
that he was told she tells Tomah the
human brain will not deteriorate if it
can perfectly memorize anything and can
in fact store 140 years worth of memory
she concludes that it is impossible in
neurology for the brain to break down no
matter how much knowledge is in it now
knowing that index shouldn't even suffer
with a knowledge inside her mind he
concludes that the church lied to style
and kanzaki and tampered with indexed
body as so she would deteriorate if her
memories were not erased every year as
such index who possesses the 103 000
grimoires would be incapable of
betraying the determined to save index
Tomah removes the bandages from his hand
and touches index's forehead hoping to
dispel something though there was no
reaction
however he notices a strange symbol
embedded inside index's mouth Tomah
inserts his middle finger into index's
mouth touching the symbol and dispels it
index Rises and charges towards him
causing an explosion which alerts
kanzaki and style a machine like indexes
speaks before them in monotonic fashion
she constructs a weapon from one of the
103 000 grimoires she has in her
possession a weapon that is the most
effective against Tomah Toma style and
kanzaki confront Jon's pen mode index
who is ready to attack Tomah suddenly
She Glows brightly and Twitches
uncontrollably before firing a beam of
energy towards Tomah who manages to
block it with his right hand meanwhile
style and kanzaki are confounded about
how index is able to perform magic Toma
tells them that the church lied to them
tomal explains that the church wouldn't
let members from the lower echelons of
the church know the entire truth behind
index
index having seen that St George
Sanctuary is ineffective against Tomah
uses a much more powerful beam of energy
on Toma because of the immense power of
her attack hona's right hand nearly
succumbs to its power however style
comes in and States his magic name
applying a large amount of runic cards
on the walls of kamui's apartment he
supports Tomah and vow to protect index
life no matter what he asks style if he
wants to save index and tells them that
this was their chance to start anew
where they don't need to erase her
memories where they don't need to act
like her enemies where everyone is happy
and had achieved the best possible
ending while saying this his hand begins
to yield against the power of index
attack however he's saved by kanzaki who
has invoked her magic name she uses her
sword and wire technique to trip index
was still firing her beam as index Falls
backward the beam points Skyward
destroying comoy's roof and a satellite
in orbit index returns to attack Tomah
abys caught unprepared by Styles summing
of an acentius which protects Tomah so
that he can charge towards index whilst
charging towards index she successfully
reverse engineers in akentius and
manages to upgrade Saint George's
Sanctuary against it however Tomah is
able to reach index in time and
successfully destroys the spell as such
Saint George's Sanctuary is dispelled
and index reverts to normal
the next day index is holding a letter
given to her by a frog-faced doctor in a
certain hospital the doctor tells index
that the letter that she is holding is
from kanzaki and style which was
intended for Toma
the letter reveals that the church
ordered them to retrieve index but after
style and kanzaki questioned them of the
truth about the church lying to them
they suddenly changed their minds and
allowed the continuation of the status
quo
the letter states that even the index is
allowed to stay with Tomah that doesn't
mean they will not come back to retrieve
her and will return once they have
gathered proper equipment for the task
the doctor states that Tomah will not
remember index as he had his memories
destroyed the memories are not simply
lost but are gone forever
index however still goes to toma's room
after seeing his face she's elated that
he is well and runs towards him but as
she approaches he asks indexed who she
is which shocks her Toma then asks if
they are familiar with each other by any
chance she asks Tomah if he remembers
where they first met how he destroyed
her walking church with his right hand
how he fought magicians for her and in
tears she asks him if he remembered that
she loved him however it was painfully
obvious to index that he could not
remember her however Tomah surprises
index by saying that it was all a ruse
of his he tells her that since his brain
cells were destroyed by Magic he need
only to touch his head with his right
hand now called imagine breaker to
negate the effect and restore his
memories index at first collapses and
relief that his memories had not been
taken but her feelings quickly turn into
Fury that he had fooled her and caused
her to confess her feelings and she
punishes him by biting him she then
storms out of his hospital room just as
the doctor is coming in when the doctor
questions Tomo's actions Tomah reveals
to him that he truly has no recollection
of index and that his power was unable
to retain any of his memories Tomah
tells the doctor the reason he lied to
index he just didn't want her to cry two
weeks had passed since the destruction
of the tree diagram style visits a
person floating upside down style calls
him Crowley and Crowley tells him the
reason he was recalled back to Academy
City their conversation is connected to
a term called Deep blood but the
situation surrounding it becoming
complicated Crowley tells style that the
person who carries deep blood is
currently imprisoned and that magicians
have become involved with the situation
even though they are normally allowed
into the city to protect the balance
between the magic and the science side
Crowley tells style that the city will
not become involved with the situation
with deep blood and suggest to him to
use the natural enemy of magicians who
Crowley has in his possession imagine
breaker Tomah before leaving style asks
if deep blood truly exists and if so
would it imply that the organism the
ability can kill should also exist the
organisms known as vampires Crowley goes
on to comment that if deep blood proves
the existence of vampires then whose
existence will the imagined breaker
prove the end of part one
sure to subscribe and hit the
notification Bell to not miss the next
part